good morning I'm here this morning my
name is Phillip pitcher I'm in the
philosophy department because I'm the
former chair of contemporary
civilization Michael Stanislavski who
would normally introduce our speaker
can't be here this morning because he's
unfortunately ill so I have the
extremely pleasant task of introducing
to you someone who most of you already
know most of you probably know Dean
moody Adams because of her tremendous
concern for students a tremendous
involvement in student issues since
she's been here on the Columbia campus
and because of her skill as an
administrator but I'm going to talk
about Dean moody Adams for just a few
minutes are not as an administrator but
as a philosopher I'm a philosopher she's
a philosopher and Dean moody Adams was
trained by one of the two or three
greatest philosophers of the last half
century John Rawls who many of you will
read at the end of contemporary
civilization before she came here of
course she taught and was an
administrator at a number of
universities most recently at Cornell
and during that period like many of John
Rawls and students she went on to
distinguish work of her own in
philosophy she is a specialist in ethics
and social philosophy and she has
written about the profound ethical and
social problems that arise for our own
time in much the way that Plato and
Aristotle and Hobbes and Kant wrote
about the profound ethical and social
problems that arose for their times and
indeed professor moody Adams Dean moody
Adams his book fieldwork in familiar
places would be a wonderful way to end
CC she's been very busy since she's come
here to Columbia as I'm sure you can
imagine but one of these days she hopes
to teach this
herself so please join me in welcoming
her for a warmer as she gives a first CC
course wide lecture
well good morning it's wonderful to see
you here and I'm excited about the
things I hope we'll talk about in the
next hour and a half or so the title of
my talk today is what difference can
theory make to practice and I thought
I'd take just a very few minutes to tell
you why I selected this topic I set
myself really three challenges as I
thought about what it might make sense
to talk about this morning the first
challenge was to try to articulate a
problem that would be likely to
encourage reflection on contemporary
civilization as a whole not just in the
part so not just particular readings you
do but as a whole the second challenge I
set myself was to link some of the
intellectual issues and challenged posed
by the readings you do in contemporary
civilization to challenges that we might
confront in other domains of inquiry and
in this case it will be particularly
running through my comments particularly
the question of how they link us up to
thinking and science but thirdly I
wanted to encourage constructive
discussion about the value of
contemporary civilization itself and
indeed about the point and the purpose
of an education in Liberal Arts and I
tell you why that last challenge is so
important to me one of the fun things
about being a philosopher you get on a
plane you sit next to an intelligent
person who asks you what you do and you
say you teach philosophy and they say oh
I love Class B I took that in college
but when people major in philosophy what
are they go on to do with it what is the
link in that sense between the theory
that you study as philosopher in
practice so as you can see it's a major
problem for people with interests in the
sort of work i have now i want to take
up the question of the link between
theory and practice and i would imagine
everybody in this room already
appreciates that this is a nagging
concern and as you'll see as i talk it's
a concern that is not confined to a
single discipline interestingly it has
been
commented on by important thinkers over
the years in ways that remind us of how
serious a problem it is in 1970 actually
speaking at the new school for social
research here in New York one of her
last public lectures the great 20th
century political philosopher Hana
errant actually suggested that modern
thought is haunted by the problem of
theory and practice and that it's just
that serious and issue that we can't not
address it and she made that observation
interestingly in a set of lectures
intended to explain how can't in his
work made the link or might have failed
in some instances to make the link
between theory and practice and one of
the most interesting things about
thinking about this concern I know that
you are reading eventually maybe even
now in this semester at least some
portions perhaps the whole of Kant's
groundwork concerning the principles of
morals it's important for you to know
they can't understood even in the 18th
century that the problem of the relation
between theory and practice was
important he's famous in fact we're
having written an essay published in
1793 that's actually called on the old
saw which is just another way of saying
the common saying it may be right in
theory but it doesn't apply in practice
and I wanted to sort of sight these two
examples to give you a sense that if
console writing about this as an old saw
common saying by 1793 probably the idea
that it was a problem with floating
around in the culture for some time so
we've got this nagging concern about
theory and practice but if we want to
understand the nature of the concern I
think the first thing we have to do is
ask what is a theory I think we'll most
of us have a pretty good working
understanding of what we mean by
practice although you may have questions
later in the question period about that
but I think the more problematic matter
is understanding what we mean by the
word theory it gets thrown around a lot
so here is what I came up with and I
want you to know this
is an experiment on my part this is some
place where i sat down about a week and
a half ago and I thought if I got asked
what a theory was what might I say so
this is still a work in progress and
feel free later to to challenge or ask
questions but I came up with the idea
that a theory is a claim or set of
claims that abstracts and either
explicitly or implicitly generalizes
about some aspect of experience or
ordinary practice and I say explicitly
or implicitly because I might want to
make certain observations about a
particular case that matter to me and
I'll show you in a moment why I think
whenever you make certain single
observations you're actually presuming a
general explanation the goal of a theory
as I have come to understand it is to
assist us in pursuing one or more of the
following aims and there might be other
things as well and you might want to
quibble with the way I've articulated
the ones on the on the screen but i
think these get at some of the main it
concerns we have we want to explain our
observations we want to understand
important concepts that structure our
observations and ground our basic
beliefs we want to predict future events
and sometimes maybe all the time we want
to act in a way that conforms to the
best and the deepest understanding of
the world and when I praised it this way
and I'm going to get back to the
explicit or implicit issue you should
understand that as you look down the
list of readings on your syllabus for cc
and you notice readings that are
important religious texts from important
traditions that we care about
understanding a religious worldview can
sometimes profitably be thought to offer
a theory of some sort maybe even more
than one theory you will hear
philosophers for instance talk about
divine command theories of morality well
I think they're understanding the
religious worldview in a way that allows
us to see it as a theory in this
but I did promise you that I would take
up that explicit or implicit issue
before I move on I might want to
understand for instance why a student in
a class of mine cheated on an exam and I
might start looking you might see well
you know he was up late and he had a lot
of other papers he had to complete and
it just looked like he couldn't do it
and gee that's why that passage from the
internet appeared full whole scale in
that paper so that's a single
explanation but I would argue that i'm
relying on general understandings of why
people might be motivated to act in a
way that's not acceptable in certain
situations rather than to do the right
thing and then i would be presupposing a
more general understanding of human
behavior in that instance so maybe
you're going to want to challenge me on
that generality of what theories offer
us but I think that's what we're trying
to do even when we theorize about a
single case so now let me turn to
another interesting set of observations
one thing we need to know is we think
about why people worry about a son
supposed gap between theory and practice
or some failure to show how theories
apply to practice is partly a function
of how theories originate and I've tried
to suggest that the standard
circumstance in which it theory arises
someone steps back from experience in
some way or other or from ordinary
practice in order to try to make sense
of the world or some part of it in a
moment of quiet as an observer or a
spectator you must for time take the
position of an observer or a spectator
in order to make sense of the world or
some part of it that's probably what
gives rise to philosophy in the first
place and later I'm going to make an
interesting reference to Hegel even
though I know you haven't gotten there
in your reading that this gets Hagel in
trouble with his later readers including
marks but one other important point the
proper development of a theory also
seems to involve an effort to somehow
show that its claims can be rationally
justified or supported in some
convincing fashion and in my
be different so if you're talking about
a theory that emerges from a religious
worldview you might not necessarily
claim that the effort involves rational
justification although you might but
still the idea that it's supported in
some convincing ways crucial and
interestingly at least as I came to
understand the problem this second
feature of theory development connects
the theory if it's done right back to
practice if it connects the theory back
to practice its effort to show how the
theory might be justified why is there a
problem and in fact some thinkers and I
will turn to an interesting
representation of these thinkers have
tried to say well there really isn't a
problem in theory but it's only in
practice that there's a problem it's one
of my favorite quotes in this area i
call it my tantalizing thought for the
day although i will conclude with
another tantalizing thought in theory it
has been said there is no difference
between theory and practice and how did
i understand this if you're doing it
right you should be able to show how the
theory connects you right back but of
course i will show in the next few
moments why in practice the effort to
make sense of that link between theory
and practice is often very hard and i
just as a little bit of levity it's not
exactly a belly laugh of any sort but if
you were to look online you wouldn't
notice that this funny little quote has
been attributed to lots of different
people the first two are maybe
understandable one of the first being a
Nobel laureate in chemistry who is
supposed to have said this at some point
in the 1960s it's been attributed to
Albert Einstein there's even a mug if
you could buy online that has this quote
on it and it says Albert Einstein but
some people claim Yogi Berra said it
Yogi Berra of all the we sort of
malapropisms that we sometimes you know
if ain't over till it's over that kind
of thing of course Yogi Berra also said
and has a book of this title I didn't
really say everything I said so how do
we know whether he said it or not but
anyway so there's that tantalizing
thought that asked
why is there a problem if we know that
when you develop a theory you need to be
able to show how it links back but there
is a problem in practice and here as I
understand the problem is how to make
sense of the various things we might be
worrying about when we say oh there's a
gap between theory and practice and it's
a general rule you know when you're
reading these texts and contemporary
civilization you will probably notice
that sometimes someone will offer some
kind of ism or some kind of claim that
once you think deeply about it tends to
conflate or run together many different
kinds of concerns and this is no more
true anywhere than it is when you're
talking about this problem of theory and
practice so here's as i was thinking
through again this is an experiment that
i put myself through and i'm taking you
through with me here's what i thought r
is the list of things most people mean
and there you will see they don't all
have equivalent consequences or
implications you might mean first that
some theories are just too remote from
practice to be informative or useful
just in a very general way without
asking what the remoteness consists in I
think a lot of times the guy that I tend
to meet on the plane sitting next to me
who's worried about theory and practice
probably means something like this
second you might mean that even theories
that seamless remote are plagued by
certain gaps and I will identify a few
of them for you between theory and
practice that aren't easily bridged you
might mean also that some domains of
inquiry just generate too many theories
too many confuse that are actually too
frequently in conflict with one another
that's a very common objection to
political and social thought you might
mean fourthly that theory and theorizing
are dangerous in some way because they
remove you too much from the world of
experience and practice they distract
you and you might mean that some
theories are intrinsically so limited by
their cultural and historical origins
that they can't be useful in other
contexts and I have to tell you that my
second week at Columbia College it
through the second weekend to the term
in the fall I
met a young woman who told me that's
exactly the problem with the readings
and contemporary civilization I have an
answer I promise I'll give it at the end
so we turn now to this larger question
of what we mean but before I get to
talking in detail about those five ways
of making sense of that charge that
theory and practice have some gap I do
want to pose something that I know will
be on your minds some of you will want
to start out thinking well there may be
a problem about theory and practice and
science but I think it's worse in social
and political thought and you know any
reasonable philosopher as I hope I am
will acknowledge that's going to be a
constant worry and I'm ready to
acknowledge the worried there might be
in your minds the thought that there's a
less tent there's a more tenuous
connection between theory and practice
perhaps in social and political thought
and some of my predecessors in the
discipline some of our great
representatives say things that tend to
feed into that view of the world and
interestingly at this quote I'm going to
I'm going to talk about in just a minute
has been cited even by other
philosophers who worry that philosophy
itself can seem too distracted but the
great Austrian philosopher Ludwig
Wittgenstein in a set of paragraphs that
were later collected together in a book
entitled zettl in German that means
scrap so it's little thoughts Vic and
Stein came up with that people collected
together mostly I think after he died
was was quoted making this observation
that the philosopher is not a citizen of
any community of ideas and that's what
makes him into a philosopher and I'm
going to actually leave that out there
is an open question whether you think
that's correct whether that's what
philosophy has to be it's clear that
there are some common subjects of
criticism amongst the readings that are
on contemporary civilization syllabus
this year some of you might want to cite
Plato's Republic I'll talk more about
the Republic later I know you read day
cards and meditations and you talk I
imagine about day cards argument that
there's a distinction a real distinction
between mind and body
there have been any number of criticisms
up to the current moment about the
remoteness of such a theory of human
functioning const ground work which
again I think many of you are either on
or about to get to count argues that
human beings have the capacity to be
motivated purely by the idea of duty and
some people wonder while we know that
people are self-interested we know they
have all these other things going on is
this too remote a picture of what's
possible and then I'll cite marks you
don't get to marks until the end but you
know even if you haven't read Marx yet
right as part of the common culture that
Marx has this view that there is a way
of leading our lives that could be
radically different from the way we lead
it now i'm calling it here on alienated
species life and some people argue that
Marx has to remote a conception of what
is possible in practice in the in the
work that he offers us in his theorizing
so I'm just throwing those issues out
there for you to think about I don't
actually believe that moral and
political thought is worse in this area
than others but I understand why the
question comes up to show you why I
don't think it's necessarily worse i'm
going to take up the chart a question of
remoteness remember my list of five
things included first the idea of
remoteness charges of remoteness ladies
and gentlemen come up in science they
come up in contemporary science and they
do so in many unexpected places and
again this was some of the research and
thinking I did sort of layered on to
thinking about the texts and
contemporary civilization but just about
the arguments that come up as you read
them how do they link up with other more
equally contemporary worries and other
disciplines so I came across first of
all and special issue of the journal
Nature I read this online and I don't
know if it was originally published in
hard copy or not but you can find it
I've given you the citation vol 4 50
number 7161 devoted this issue of nature
a part of it to talking about the
relationship between what people in bio
oh gee conservation biology do and
others who are practitioners and there's
a wonderful editorial in this issue
announcing there's a big gap between
theory of the in conservation biology
and the practice of people who are
actually on the ground doing the work
and biologists are worried about why
they can't have more direct impact and
the practitioners are worried about why
they should be listening to these
theories that seemed to them to cut off
from the work they do and the editor is
saying look why would anybody go into
conservation biology unless they cared
about conserving species why assume that
the theory is intrinsically too remote
what do the biologists need to do to
make the links to practice clearer but
then I found a second example that was
even in some ways more interesting
because it wasn't about non-scientists
talking to scientists it was about
scientists who see themselves in one
light as purely experimental biologists
in this case interested in the
functioning of the human brain about
those Sciences looking at the work of
people in computational neuroscience who
offer very elaborate theoretical models
that take together take into account all
sorts of elaborate data that you
couldn't as a single an experimental
person in the field a mass in any
ordered way and they claim to offer up
models elaborate theoretical models to
help understand the functioning of the
brain and it turns out that a lot of the
experimental biologists look at them and
say what are we supposed to do with this
how do I translate this into my practice
as an experimental biologists this was
in nature neuroscience also available
online December 2005 this was an entire
issue devoted to trying to convince
experimental biologists with an interest
in the brain that they could learn from
the computational neuroscientist but we
can talk about a remedy for remoteness
and I think it's important to say right
off maybe it is going to be easier in
the sciences but the remedy is to try to
strike a better balance between theory
and practice and some of the things you
might do this is not a complete list
so because my question is how can theory
make a difference to practice well
here's a case try to get better
communication between the theorists and
the practitioners and interestingly
we'll have to understand practitioner in
a very broad way in the neuroscience
case perhaps present your theoretical
findings if you're doing the theory
yourself in a manner that can be grasped
by non-specialists by the practitioners
in a field as well as fingers and other
related fields seize opportunities to
show how the complex theoretical model
might meet the practitioners needs it's
fairly clear the reading I did of that
conservation biology case suggests that
the biologists weren't helping the park
managers for instance understand why
their theories mattered and then be
ready to show how your theoretical model
or principle can survive an appropriate
test of validity why should this theory
we thought the right one for the work
you're doing now some of you are going
to say that's all well and good in the
case of a scientific theory but maybe
their special problems for non
scientific thought and again I
understand what generates this worry and
so I pose some questions I have
particular answers to these questions
that I think will be of value to you one
of the problems is in the non-scientific
case clearly demarcating the
practitioner from the theorists and
interestingly sometimes you have to do
that in your own case right sometimes
you're the observer in one walk of life
and then you're the actor and but you've
got to be able to articulate clearly for
the for the process who the
practitioners are and what they need to
know the second thing to do is it's
question rather is whether they're
appropriate standards for demonstrating
validity that sorry whether what are the
appropriate standards excuse me in a
non-scientific case for demonstrating
validity I will later make an argument
that it doesn't need to be a matter of
standards that look just like those in
science I won't be able to make the
whole argument in the time
it to me today but I will hint at an
answer that I hope might seem intriguing
then there's the question connect it to
the former question of whether the
standards embodied and scientific
theorizing have to be deemed the only
ones that make sense in non-scientific
thought if you think the answer to that
question is yes I may not at this point
have much more to say to convince you
otherwise I will accept that but as any
theorists would do I would hope that you
would attend to the theory I will at
least hint out later and consider the
possibility that the answer to that
question is no but if the answer is yes
then there would be a problem about how
non-scientific theorizing could
genuinely conform to standards of
validity I'm going to leave that out
there is a problem I spent a fair amount
of my time as a philosopher for into the
last 10 years thinking through the
relationship between theorizing and
science and non-scientific theorizing
but I understand there are recalcitrant
views and it will still take more
arguments till we can come to that later
so I've talked about remoteness and how
you might solve the problem of
remoteness to make it possible for
theory to have it make a good difference
in practice but then there's that second
worry I identified about gaps in our
understanding of what a theory means to
us potential gaps actually not just an
understanding but some of them are so
let me acknowledge those gaps get
articulated and try and say something
about them the first we might
acknowledge a gap in that involves a
difficulty of interpretation you read
the Constitution in contemporary
civilization you may or may not have
thought about it as embodying a theory
but I offer to you the thought that it
embodies a theory and that the theory
embodied in it grounds and amendment in
this case declaring cruel and unusual
punishment incompatible with the dignity
due to a citizen but we know from the
history of constitutional interpretation
that the challenge of making sense of
what cruel and unusual means white we
understand
things clearly flogging public flogging
of people in certain settings perhaps is
cruel and unusual but is putting people
to death by a lethal injection cruel and
unusual we understand there can be
difficulties of interpretation and that
will lead us to worry about a gap we can
worry secondly about the understanding
of a theory being difficult when we
don't know how to interpret how to apply
the theory in practice Erie in practice
if the Ten Commandments so you read the
Ten Commandments as part of your reading
in CC declared thou shalt not kill does
the proper application of that rule
allow us to justify killing in
self-defense some people immediately
will say of course and others for
instance the Amish will say of course
not and the very fact that we can differ
so profoundly in the application leads
to a worry that there is some kind of
difficult gap now here's how I think we
can address the gap in understanding so
I'm always going to try to address the
problem first aim for interpretive
transparency sometimes this means
restating a difficult rule in lots of
different ways again you're going to
read if you aren't already there Kant's
groundwork of the medical grounds and
the metaphysics of morals and you will
be surprised some people are in fact
angered by the fact that Conte will
offer several different versions of the
main principle he wants you to
understand and apply as I interpret
Conte when I read this so gives us three
formulations of his main formula he'll
say things like apps in such a way that
you always treat humanity always as an
end in itself and never as a means only
elsewhere he's talked about acting so
that your you could make the rule
underlying your action become a
universal law people say how do those
things fit together I argue that he's
giving us and he's aiming at
interpretive transparency to try to
understand there will be different
contexts in which and even different
needs that practitioners have
that require them to have the rule
expressed in lots of different ways and
interestingly for as difficult as it is
to read Khan I think he actually does a
better job of addressing the theory
practice gap than a lot of other
philosophers brilliant though they are
who may be in style stylistically less
difficult to read so you might have to
restate the rule a lot another way to
address the gap in understanding is to
accept a certain truth about general
principles and rules one very central
truth and contacts who writes about this
in his theory practice essay that the
truly general and usefully general rule
is not going to be self interpreting and
one of the things that makes it not self
interpreting in fact is the thing that
we most value them for and that's that
they have an openness to the richness of
human experience a great philosopher of
law named HLA heart calls this the open
texture of general rules it's both the
wonderful part of our ability to use and
apply general rules and it's one of the
greatest challenges but I think what it
means which many philosophers have
encouraged us to think is that you need
to be cultivating something we call
judgment sound judgment so you bridge
that gap by understanding you need
judgment and the rule can't do it for
you no no philosopher articulating a
rule can do it for you and the second
bullet here sound judgment about the
open textured notion has to be
cultivated how can it be cultivated i'm
not sure if it can be taught but i think
you've cultivated you need a readiness
to deliberate with appropriate others
and that of course is what you learned
from aristotle and you need to be ready
to draw on the judgment of people who
are good at making the judgments i call
them exemplar zai use the example of the
moral exemplar but it could be a great
somebody who's especially good at
applying conservation biology in the
field could be a biological exemplar if
you will so that's a response but then
there's a second category of gaps and
this is not going to be
easy as easy to address and I'm not
going to claim in this time available to
me to do it and that's a gap that we
think of as motivational and what I've
done here I'm not going to try to go
through all of them but I'm not going to
explain them all i'm just going to list
some that people worry about people
worry about how plato comes to assume he
could protect the ideal political
society from deterioration we know that
he posits the possibility of telling a
lie a noble lie at least this is one of
the things he posits and that suggests
many people have thought there is some
kind of motivational gap that's profound
in the theory Hobbs you read Leviathan
how does Hobbes expect that people seem
to care only about their self-interest
and about things that promote self
interest that they might be motivated to
take part in a cooperative venture of
political society remember if you you're
reading and Hobbes the war of all
against all that will result if we don't
do things differently well there's a
motivational problem there Hobbes talks
about laws of reason that will get you
there but the laws of reason end up
telling you you need to give over your
authority to another entity to an
absolute sovereign and there's evidence
that Hobbes was aware of a motivational
gap I've already mentioned can't the
idea of the dear self the self
interested person how do you get them to
act from motive of duty I should say how
is it possible some people might worry
about mill you're going to read mill
later and he talks about tolerance and
we know how deeply connected we are to
our own opinions how can we be expected
to live in a society that demands that
we are tolerant of things that may wound
us I'm actually going to leave the marks
out for now but you'll can talk later
about the issue of alienated workers so
these are problems and the philosophers
who articulate the theories understand
them I do think there is one interesting
gambit open to the really thoughtful
theorists and you are reading only
thoughtful theorists in this
course one gambit is to say look so
maybe I can't convince you the same way
I might in science that this will meet
your needs as the practitioner but if
you read the theory hard enough and you
understand that what I've done is give
you a conception better than you
understand now of what it is to be a
fully human being what it is an effect
to be you at your best contemplate the
theory hard honest you will actually
come to see yourself reflected in some
interesting way in the theory and this
is an important gambit it doesn't always
work as the theorists hopes but one of
the reasons we read the text we do in CC
is because the exercise of having to
rethink reimagine yourself conception
has a profound and I think intrinsic
value but you can see this at work in
some of the great texts you're reading
con talks about offering really a more
rational but a reconstruction of the way
human beings actually already think he's
calling you back to yourself and then
your job as the reader of the theory has
to be to ask well does this really match
a conception of what it is to really be
a being of the kind we are Aristotle I
think weird argue that his conception
best captures what your nature requires
if you are to lead your best and
happiest life it's a common gambit and
it may be in the end even if you're not
convinced that they have depicted your
self-conception accurately the sort of
things that you have to do to
contemplate the theory produce a level
of reflection that is intrinsically
worthwhile that is one of the things I'm
going to defend now I'm just going to
leave out the worry about about some of
the other theorists but I offer this as
a possibility if part of the power part
of the importance of a non-scientific
theory is that it provides you this
opportunity to contemplate different
conceptions of what it is to be human
and to consider what it might mean to
reshape your self-conception accordingly
if that's part of their power it might
be the even if you never agreed with all
the
tenants of a theory it had done
something more important than any other
kind of inquiry imaginable or at least I
won't say more important but as
important as what a theory in science
can do and I've actually got an issue
here about Plato it's just reiterating
the motivational concern I'm not going
to belabor this point you already know
that I think there's an issue at stake
in Plato's willingness even for a very
short stretch in the Republic to try and
fill the his motivational gap with a
noble lie and I will just leave that out
there if you understand I think that's a
problem I do want to get to one more gap
some people say there's an attainability
gap that is also deeply problematic and
to two examples here you read also the
New Testament and then the fundamental
commands the idea is can be subsumed
under a single requirement to love God
and love thy neighbor as thyself does
this set an unattainable standard what
if your neighbor is a horrible violent
evil human being but think of the case
of the Amish in the example of
forgiveness when they suffered one of
the greatest wrongs of people of
community can suffer were several of
their young people middle school aged
girls were put to death at the hands of
a very unhappy and mentally a disturbed
individual they forgave they
demonstrated the possibility perhaps at
least we think they did it of this
allegedly unattainable gap so maybe we
need to find examples of people who at
least seem to have shown us how to
bridge the attainability gap another
example I've talked about can't already
and his insistence that yes we have
self-interest and it's a powerful motive
but we can sometimes act on duty Cantus
con is clear that he thinks it's a
possibility but even contact knowledge
is that you can't really know in your
own case always whether or not you
have conformed to the motive of duty i'm
not going to read the passage but I've
quoted a place but there is a wonderful
passage and contents in page 59 in your
volume we actually says you know even
though I can't be sure in any case
whether somebody acted from the motive
of duty he says there's nobody not even
the most hardened scoundrel who if you
show them an example of what seems to be
a case and give them a sense of the
possibility i should say of acting from
this pure motive that they will
understand that it is an attainable
standard now the example isn't there to
be the educating thing you're supposed
to know and cons view that you can do it
but the very fact that Kant thinks that
even the most hardened person can be
made to think it's attainable it is an
important fact so how do you address the
attainability gap well here's what I
would say and there are three main
things the first is suppose some of the
theories you've read do offer seemingly
unattainable standards that's not a bad
thing leading a good life and here I'm
talking as an individual just as hard
and there's something of value I would
argue about setting a standard high and
then demanding of yourself that you try
to aim it I will acknowledge that
defining and protecting defensible forms
of social and political organization may
be even harder there's where Hobbes and
Locke and mill and others in that and
Plato come in it's very difficult thing
but I will state as clearly as I can
that I think there is profound value
even nobility and dignity just in the
effort to conform even to a difficult
standard even if you can't be sure that
you can actually do it and even if
despite knowing that you could conform
you might never feel satisfied with your
effort to do so so that's for me how you
bridge that gap between allegedly
unattainable theory and practice keep
trying and there's something valuable in
the effort too many theories with too
much conflicting content the too many
Theory argument a lot of you may say we
read Pioli with Aristotle which one
should we believe
and in fact a lot of my colleagues and
philosophy sometimes will argue the
danger of some kinds of introductory
philosophy courses you're not reading
only philosophy is that it turns people
into skeptics others will worry whether
there's something wrong with a body of
inquiry that doesn't seem to make any
progress and what do I mean if you
understand progress as a movement
towards a single theory of what is the
right way to lead your life surely the
whole of human thought does not offer
that kind of progress some people think
there's too much conflict between the
theories and the event that it can
encourage skepticism but here is my
answer maybe the domain of moral and
political thought whether it's a
religious worldview that's offering you
a divine command theory of morality or
secular philosophical view maybe it
starts having to make sense of a realm
of experience that's just too
complicated to hope for converging on a
single theory there's a great early 20th
century moral philosopher who actually
said why would you assume that a realm
of experience moral experience is
complexity as it is might be something
that a single thinker could be able to
come up with a single theory to make
sense of everything to offer you the
whole truth and nothing but the truth
and so I would extend this to all of
social and political thought why assume
that the only respectable forms of
theoretical inquiry are those that
aspire towards convergence on a single
view what else might we hope they could
do stimulate that self-reflection that I
talked about the kind of self-reflection
that isn't possible in other contexts
opening up the possibility of seeing
yourself in a new way theories that are
non-scientific if they're properly done
can offer powerful thought experiments
about the way the world ought to look
and about what people would need to do
to make it happen useful theoretical
models for reflection on the nature of
social life and in my third bullet they
offer you these experiments without
having to sacrifice any real people
without violating anybody's he
dignity or without destroying existing
social and political forms right and we
know the history of some experiments in
scientific campaigns where we couldn't
say the same thing about the
experimental effort of the theorists and
then finally we would hope they could
articulate important ideals in practice
so that would be my argument about
bridging that gap I want to take up to
last challenges that people will offer
one of them is that theory is
intrinsically a dangerous distraction
there are lots of different versions of
this takes you away from practice and
makes you not makes you impatient with
the messiness of experience and i want
to say i know this is a tempting view
but i'm going to argue that it's
dangerous to give in to the temptation
for one very simple reason and that's in
bullet to there has to be room and I say
not just in moral and political thought
but in scientific inquiry for what we
call basic research doesn't have the
same character necessarily in science as
it doesn't the non-science area but for
theoretical reasoning that may not have
any immediate implication for ordinary
practice you can't be the one who knows
which theory will produce the best
results or whether simply the activity
of engaging in the kind of theorizing
I've described might have an intrinsic
value in itself when it's taking you
away from things you ought to do
obviously there are worries and I would
be ready to address them I wouldn't want
you to spend 24 hours reading
contemporary civilization there'd be
other things you have to eat yet to
sleep you have to do other things but
there is a value to them I'd like to
preserve so I want to do before I get to
the concluding problem I just want to
sum up the things I've offered in it in
response to four of the five challenges
to theory and practice the first is I
say look acknowledge the intrinsic value
of theories that may not yield immediate
practical results and this may be as
important for the theoretical physicist
right as for the philosopher thinking
about the nature of political
organization
in the domain of moral and political
thought acknowledge the value of open
textured rules we get impatient for
instance with a rule that says do not
kill we get impatient with a cruel and
unusual punishment prohibition but look
at the power such rules have to offer us
guidance over centuries and even
millennia in a way that nothing else in
the way of a rule might do you've got to
be ready to cultivate good judgment
you've got to ask how that might happen
who is a good deliberative partner who
is a good moral exemplar you have to ask
those questions three other things allow
that the process of merely contemplating
a theory can be central to your effort
to cultivate good judgment another
reason to read the texts and CC remain
open fourthly to the possibility that
some kinds of theory are more important
for their capacity to lead us to see
ourselves in a different way than for
their internal completeness or their
tendency to lead to a single theory on
which every other view of the world
converges and then finally maybe the
most important acknowledge the value of
moral and political aspirations that may
outstrip our known powers to meet them
then there is a final challenge and it's
a challenge that probably you have
friends maybe at other institutions of
for the sophomores and students in the
room who want to know why are you doing
these things are there some moral and
political theories Aristotle Plato we
could go down the list to tied to their
origins particularly cultural and maybe
also historical origins to be generally
useful and maybe in a way that wouldn't
be a problem in the area of Nan
scientific theory and I'm here to tell
you that I've spent probably 20 years on
this one answering the question Mme not
the ones that really matter why do I
think that theoretical concepts and
principles with fundamental moral and
political importance it turns out over
and over again it turns out that they
cannot be the property of any single
theorists any single culture
or any single historical movement within
a culture two quick examples the idea of
moral and political equality in the
American context it was formulated by a
thinker a great thinker but a thinker
named Thomas Jefferson who failed in
interesting ways to appreciate what his
theory should have led him to conclude
about slavery he was a genius I don't
want to get rid of Jefferson I love
Jefferson but he failed okay but his
failure was not sufficient was not it
was not a sign of an of the ideas
limitations it was a sign in fact I and
as you say the history as a sign that
the idea of equality that he formulates
in the Declaration of Independence was
even greater than he was he didn't own
it he couldn't define its boundaries he
couldn't tell us how it's open texture
should be interpreted the concept of
Rights right we say oh it's a Western
idea and G nobody outside the West can
use it well no way you could have seen
about 15 years ago a representative of a
South American native people indigenous
people called the Yanomamo march up to
the front podium of the United Nations
and declare that they had a right of
cultural survival they took a Western
concept and they used it in defense of a
culture that was decidedly and is
decidedly non-western that's a sign of
the power of the ideas you ought to care
about and the ideas I want you to take
seriously so in conclusion I offer up
two observations because no culture can
claim exclusive rights to a concept of
genuinely fundamental moral importance
any human being can be a participant in
the tradition that begins with Plato and
Aristotle and in quotes all the usual
suspects in contemporary civilization I
believe that as fully as I believe
anything I ever believed
second conclusion though the core has
rightly expanded its intellectual and
cultural reach beyond the West and I
stand here to defend the value of that
the theories and arguments that you
grapple with in the traditional texts of
contemporary civilization continue to be
worth your while it's tempting to say oh
gee we've moved on what's the future you
know these offer these arguments that
sometimes are 2,000 years old but let me
give you my concluding observation of
final yogi ism the future ain't what it
used to be thank
I know some of you have to go because
you have many other things going on in
your lives and I'm grateful for those of
you who will who were here today but
those of you who are still here may have
questions and if you've got questions
feel free to step up to the microphone
and we can take them
any questions maybe I answered all the
problems that would be rare actually
we've got a questioner um I'm interested
in the ways in which concepts their
theories frameworks that or that
originated in a particular cultural
context and which which in a culture can
be appropriated into a into another
context but by another group for lack of
a better term which which which which
the originating culture has been
perceived as oppressing in some way the
example that comes to mind comes who was
related by Martha Nussbaum which she
talks about a group of Chinese women
intellectuals who actually repudiate who
actually were repudiating Confucian
Daoists traditions on the grounds that
they those traditions had a prep that
illustration though their local
traditions that oppressed them and
instead appropriating Wollstonecraft
mill etc for use in for use in their
strut in there and in their struggle for
for equality and I and I wonder I mean
wondering about do you think you could
you could discourse a bit more on that
okay there are a couple of different
things bound up in your concern one of
them is the question of whether it's a
reasonable justifiable use of a concept
that's formulated in another culture to
use it to undermine the culture you're
in so that's one thing you're worried
about or potentially and not so but I'm
not so much worried
but how does it happen well I have a
quick theory a quick answer about how it
happens that will maybe trouble some
people and the argument I want to make
is one of the reasons a concept that we
initially think is alien to our culture
can have any resonance in our culture so
in fact probably cultures are more
complicated theoretically conceptually
from the very beginning then we
acknowledge what do I mean by that I
would bet you that there is some analog
in the culture that Professor Nussbaum
describes that is officially confusion
but some analog of some profoundly non
Confucian concepts already cultures I I
argue are complicated and that's
probably from my mind why I'm so
confident that one idea can never be the
property of the culture that first
articulates it because probably that
effort to articulate it is echoing
something that could be could have been
are you could bite and just by accident
emerged in the West or wherever but it
could have been articulated anywhere for
me that is what makes it fundamental
that does that help maybe not every yeah
I think yeah I think that that is that
that is helpful thing and that's
controversial because it's a way of
denying some of the individuality of
different cultures that some people who
do anthropological theory have tried to
argue for but I my view is that cultures
are always from the very beginning even
the seemingly most simple cultures their
internally complex and their complexity
allows them to contain many ideas that
don't ever get official statement but
maybe echoing something that's coming
from outside the help that's
controversial but that's the view that I
like to take other any other questions
hi thank you for speaking today but um
so in science many times when
experimenters find a new discovery that
maybe contradicts a theory the theorists
changed the theory and reformulate it so
in our current age there are many
scientific discoveries into how
psychology works or how our bodies work
or
how humans function in general that
these experimenters are found so how do
you think these new discoveries should
interact with our maybe moral
formulations that philosophers think of
you guys are really big question it
wouldn't it depend on what the content
of the new theories you're describing is
there is a very powerful movement of
foot and contemporary moral philosophy
just to take one example that has argued
that moral philosophers who just
abstract from experience in one way need
to come back into the world and need to
be doing experiments not just thought
experiments but real experiments and
that they need to be listening more to
science but it would depend to my mind
on the content of the theory in question
and on also your willingness to accept
the possibility that science may not I
know this might be a heresy for some
people but it may not be able to tell us
everything we need to know about
important areas of human concern we
might never i would suggest want to
think of ourselves as needing to get to
a position where we as non-scientific
theorists in my case gave over the whole
of human of the effort to understand
human experience to the experimental
scientist it might be that there's some
domains of the experience that aren't
captured maybe isn't that why you read
the books you read and literature
humanities that there might be some soy
f all for that as an open question
acknowledging that science obviously is
not irrelevant if we've got some deeply
problematic understanding about human
about the possibility of human action
about whether we have free will for
instance or not and i know there will be
some in the room who deny that some of
my colleagues on very interestingly
reasonable and reflective grounds would
deny it but if science showed us
something that we didn't fully
appreciate before about the
possibilities and the limits of human
action obviously moral theory might have
to change in response but i'm here to
tell you i'm not convinced that we've
gotten there yet or that we ever will
so but I know that it puts me in a
certain category of people with a
certain stance other other questions I
have one question um it was kind of the
opposite problem with what you were
discussing is when a like a harmful or a
problematic theory is all too readily
you know accepted and put into practice
and you know to take an example you know
like racial purity and Nazi Germany or
like apocalyptic theories you know in
fundamental religious cults or whatever
and it's kind of paradoxical because
then you have this really monstrous
theory that is you know accepted and by
a lot of people and does that make it a
successful theory in some kind of dark
way so that's a very good question
missing from today's remarks was an
account of what I think has to be true
of something to constitute a fundamental
moral concept or principle very
deliberately missing because it would
have taken another 40 minutes to fully
but here's my thought here's what I've
come to over the years any concept and
any theory that contains it which you
need to coerce me into believing or
course some body into believing or for
which belief or acceptance requires
violence to suppress disagreement would
not qualify as a fundamental moral
concept so the racial purity the people
who are being discriminated against on
the ground of the theory are going to
object if the silence their objection
you have to do away with them which we
know history has shown has happened my
argument is the theory that contains
such a principle fails to qualify as a
genuinely defensible moral theory if
you've got a course mean I have other
arguments I could offer for why I think
coercion and violence play the role that
they do it's actually a Socratic
argument that the I actually think this
has maybe even state as
fundamental moral notion whether I want
to call it a principle now there's
another issue you can never know whether
you might be wrong and if to get me to
believe your theory you have to silence
me then you have demonstrated a kind of
assumption of your own infallibility
that doesn't comport with the facts so I
would argue I'm glad you asked that
question because it was I kept saying to
myself should I spill the beans about
this that I think this I figured
somebody would ask about well they're
definitely gazes where you actually have
a distance theory from practice with
that there are definitely cases where
you actually have to distance theory
from practice absolutely and so if you
read Plato and even if you're angry with
Plato and maybe some of you who've read
other dialogues besides a republic would
have had this experience of getting
angry with the figure of Socrates in
them the very fact that you're still
there to get angry and that you can
throw the book down and you can move
away that's a different Enterprise
altogether the Platonic enterprise of
trying to convince you even if it makes
you mad very different from somebody
saying either this theory rains or we do
away with the and you accept it or we do
away with you we do away with dissent
and criticism things hi thank you so
much for the talk is great oh you're
welcome I had a question you spoke about
acknowledging that some theories may
take more time to actually seem
practical or more time to develop and we
need to spend that time however how do
you deal with the limitations of being a
human being that needs to take care of
the basic thing and sometimes those
things distract us away from theorizing
or like trying to become that great
being for example described in some of
the books how do you reach that gap this
is a major concern not just for
philosophers but for anybody human
there's the role of the observer and the
spectator and then there's the role of
the actor the do or the practitioner and
a good life is one in which you try to
strike the right balance between them
and I'm here to acknowledge that there
are some ways of doing things
science I would argue where we are
failing to strike there where something
is out of balance something is out of
whack could I offer you a formula for
saying when that balance has been or
could I offer you a formula for finding
the balance no could I offer you a
foolproof method of getting yourself
back into balance when you've somehow
gotten out of it no but I will suggest
that one of the most powerful things
about moral experience moral inquiry
just an impractical thought in general
so not just the scientific thought is
that we do have in our experience
profound examples of lives that are led
this is one of the interesting things I
think about Aristotle and I acknowledge
her I have a dangerous habit
occasionally of being the kind of
picking and choosing the great ideas
from the great thinkers this is one
where I think Aristotle gets it right I
could give you as many theories even
rules of thumb about how to lead a good
life as possible but in the end until
you can see it embodied in the life of a
person you know to be doing well being
happy living good it will not I think
have the proper effect and so no Theory
no formula but there are people we can
point to at least we hope we can point
to how we identify them as hard but you
need to work hard I think to find and
identify those moral exemplars to lead
to in order to lead a good life and
sometimes they just jump out at us
cultures may argue about who they are
but we know some of them just jump out
at us one of the reasons a person like
Gandhi for instance jumps out even of
people who may not share all of his
political commitments will acknowledge
the ability of somebody to stand and
with withstand certain kinds of violence
and efforts to course and not give up on
the principles and not hurt anybody else
in the process that for me would be one
such moral example I could offer many
more I don't want to say that that's all
that leading a good life comes to but
that when it's hard and when striking
the right theory practice balance is
difficult you may have no choice but to
turn to the exemplar any other questions
at this stage in history it's been
argued that there are no real remaining
ideological competitors the ideas of
democracy and capitalism how does that
affect or change the relevance of social
theorizing your your comment before how
does it change no competitors to what
was the thing democracy and capitalism
hmm I'm not sure I'm ready to accept
that I love democracy I'd visit it was
it Churchill who said it may not be
perfect but it's the you know the best
thing we've got so far so I have no
problem with it I'm not entirely sure
that we've exhausted the possibility of
human political organization so that
would be my answer it I know it's been
said but we know there are flaws we know
it's also difficult to defend and I had
a wonderful argument in fact with my
daughter this morning about the dangers
if you're a plate unless right if you're
if you think like Plato that democracy
sometimes is too easily likely to
degenerate into things that are not
desirable forms of life so maybe
democracy isn't perfect either but I
would also argue I'm not sure we've
exhausted all the possibilities and
that's why another reason why the
theorizing that gives people a little
room to experiment in thought anyway I
think is a good thing but you're by I
know that that's an issue but I don't
accept that view of history so thank you
please give dean moody out of the tape
man
you